la guerra en ucrania representa un
desafío para la organización del tratado
del atlántico norte otan sus miembros se
han reunido en múltiples ocasiones desde
el inicio del conflicto buscando la
manera de brindar apoyo a quien al mismo
tiempo evitando entrar en una
confrontación directa con rusia la
expansión de la otan fue uno de los
principales motivos que llevaron a
vladimir putin a lanzar su invasión a
ucrania el kremlin ha condenado la
expansión de la otan que se encuentra
cada vez más cerca de sus fronteras ha
exigido que el bloque militar retire su
armamento de europa del este- y también
que sea vetado el ingreso de ucrania a
la alianza sin embargo el efecto podría
terminar siendo el contrario al
ucraniano para alejarse de sus
aspiraciones países tradicionalmente
neutros como suecia y finlandia sopesan
la posibilidad de unirse a la otan para
blindarse de una eventual agresión rusa
al estar bajo el paraguas de protección
del artículo 5
y ha lanzado advertencias a estos o
países nórdicos y justamente hoy amenazó
con un despliegue nuclear en el báltico
si llegaran a concretarse dichas
adhesiones para ello entonces quiero
saludar a nuestro primero invita a
nuestro primer invitado el día el es
antonio barrios oviedo analista
especialista en conflictos
internacionales el origen y ampliación
de la otan a docente invitado de la
universidad de medio oriente gracias
antonio por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 a su manera
de ver cómo ha manejado la otan la
situación con respecto a la guerra en
ucrania bueno la ha manejado yo creo que
desde el punto de vista diplomático fue
una guerra que pudo haberse
perfectamente evitado yo creo que la
unificación de las políticas exteriores
de los países de la unión europea o en
este caso digamos de la alianza
atlántica hubieran hecho más para evitar
la guerra sin embargo yo creo que
recordemos un poco lo que pasó en el
2008 cuando ucrania estuvo en la lista
de espera al igual que georgia para ser
parte de la otan y sin embargo bueno
este eso fue una situación que
definitivamente fue escalando digamos
con un mayor nivel de tensión hasta que
tenemos este conflicto evidentemente el
país que invade ucrania es rusia no en
ningún otro país de europa pero desde el
punto de vista diplomático si hay muchos
especialistas a nivel mundial y sobre
todo en europa que consideran de que la
esta guerra nuclear ya perfectamente se
pudo haber evitado bueno
desafortunadamente hay una guerra en
este momento en ucrania que tiene que
ver cómo se puede resolver lo más pronto
posible para que no escale incluso a
niveles mayores porque hay un temor
evidente en europa de que esto pueda
llevar a una escalada mayor que
evidentemente europa no no va a poder
incluso contener
así que la guerra en ucrania pues lo que
un ahora es un tema de negociación
yo creo que deben haber países garantes
en europa no solamente de la de la
delegación de ucrania y la delegación de
rusia que procuran poner fin al
conflicto digamos un poco previendo
todas estas exigencias o la ola o la
demanda de putin yo creo que ahora le
compete a europa tratar de ver cómo
desde el punto de vista diplomático
logra que estas negociaciones se
profundicen al punto de que ya se llegue
a un fin en este conflicto claro antonio
en esta verdad y viajamos entonces al
ámbito diplomático vamos adelante y al
ahora digamos que se pudo haber hecho
antes para poder evitar esta guerra qué
tipo de esfuerzos hubieran hecho los
países europeos para evitarla como usted
bien lo dice y en la actualidad también
hablemos de esta vía diplomática parece
que pues las opciones sobre la mesa se
están cada día agotando y qué tiene que
pasar en la actualidad para sentar las
partes y realmente buscar una paz
duradera y estable y que este tipo de
guerras no se vuelvan a seguir viendo
bueno yo creo que ya lo había dicho
henry kissinger déjenme destacar un
poquito un artículo interesante que le
había escrito hace un tiempo en el donde
en el 2000 en el 2015 cuando le había
hablado de que ucrania iba a ser un
dolor de cabeza para la seguridad
europea en efecto si fue por lo que ya
anteriormente había dicho de lo ocurrido
en el 2008 que ucrania y georgia estaban
en estar en esta famosa lista de espera
para incorporarse a la otan entonces
bueno aquí siquiera había dicho y esto
digamos en este momento resuena
fuertemente de que ucrania no le queda
más que optar por la idea de islandia es
decir esta famosa neutralidad finlandia
que incluso en distintas encuestas los
finlandeses consideran de que esta
neutralidad les ha beneficiado más que
con rusia digamos que ser parte de la
otan sobre todo también porque el caso
de suecia y finlandia son muy
interesantes es decir no hay apoyo
ciudadano real como para que sean parte
de la otan y ya se ha hablado que
ucrania no tenía que veganos seguir ese
paso recordemos que la posición
geográfica de ucrania la ubica en un
punto delicado un punto intermedio en
esto que yo llamo la frontera final
entre lo que significa la seguridad en
europa a través de la línea atlántica y
lo único que le queda digamos a rusia en
cuanto a lo que consideran que de
seguridad y la posición geográfica de
ucrania desafortunadamente la coloca en
un punto muy complicado en ese sentido
así que la diplomacia europea bien
insisto pudo haber hecho más en el
sentido de que jamás debieron digamos
haber contemplado la idea de hacer
posible la incorporación de ucrania a la
otan sobre todo también porque si uno ve
la posición geográfica de los países
bálticos los países bálticos tienen una
frontera compartida con la frontera
natural de rusia y fueron los países que
en 1999 se incorporaron a la otan
entonces eso rusia lo ve como un tema
delicado en el balance de la seguridad
en europa en la cual pues rusia necesita
también tener un espacio neutral para
entonces tener digamos rusia en este
caso pues una un margen digamos de de
maniobrabilidad respecto de lo que
significa la seguridad al menos en
términos
y rusos así que bueno hay aquí hay una
situación muy complicada porque
desafortunadamente hay una guerra en
ucrania en este momento
presente y yo creo que la diplomacia
ahora puede dar un giro radical de lo
que significa digamos la situación en
este momento de cómo buscar un ego de
una negociación más profunda para evitar
ya una guerra una guerra nueva chad y en
virtud también de ver cómo se logra
solucionar la que tienen en este momento
en ucrania ahora antonio vamos a hablar
de estos dos países neutrales que están
sobre la mesa incluso hoy porque el ex
presidente de rusia además miembro
activo en la actualidad del gobierno del
presidente ruso vladimir putin hablamos
de dimitri medvedev amenazó con un
despliegue de armas nucleares en el
bálticos y su éxito en la cndh ya
ingresan a la otan realmente es posible
que estos dos países ingresen a la
alianza y recordamos también que los
países bálticos dijeron pues esto no va
a cambiar no va a ser de nada porque
igual hay armamento nuclear y hay este
tipo de armas en el báltico así que da
lo mismo si ingresamos a la otan o no
entonces qué está pasando realmente con
estos dos países y con la neutralidad de
la que
hace hace un pasado que todo cambio
digamos ahora y la seguridad de europa
es diferente
bueno ya hecho finlandia y suecia ya han
dicho de que precisamente por temor a
una agresión por parte de rusia por lo
que están por lo que se está viviendo en
ucrania y de lo que incluso rusia pues
ha demostrado en este momento ser capaz
yo creo que ya el mito está de la
universalidad se ha venido cayendo este
gradualmente es decir muy pocos meses
todo lo que todavía el año pasado se
consideraba de que ser parte de la otan
pues no era necesario al menos dentro
del dentro del dentro del concepto de la
ciudadanía de que no consideran que ser
parte de la otan sea ningún beneficio
por lo menos no era una cuestión de
urgencia ahora de febrero a marzo de
este año ha habido algunas encuestas
interesantes tanto en suecia como en
finlandia en donde incluso ha llegado
hasta el parlamento y ha habido
discusión en el parlamento de estos dos
países sobre este famoso mito de la
neutralidad y ya están incluso
contemplando de que tienen toda la
libertad de ser parte de la otan de
hecho la otan ya había manifestado a
través del secretario general
stoltenberg cuando dijo de que
evidentemente suecia y finlandia en
tiene la puerta abierta en el momento
que lo consideran sobre todo por
tratarse de que tienen gobiernos que
digamos son afín a la forma en cómo se
gobiernan en este caso en europa
occidental
democracias liberales hay elecciones
alternas etcétera etcétera entonces hay
una serie de características que los
llevan a ser parte eventualmente de la
otan y yo creo que ya eso es un tema que
a raíz de lo que está pasando en ucrania
pues hay un temor evidente de estos dos
países de lo que puede llegar a ocurrir
sobre todo finlandia que es la que
comparte frontera natural con rusia lo
ve digamos como más una situación de
amenaza que en sí lo que pudo haber
significado en el pasado la neutralidad
de 1947 es como finlandia se ha venido
perfilando digamos en esta condición
frente a rusia así que bueno la guerra
en ucrania ha cambiado las condiciones
en europa y países que históricamente
han sido neutrales pues están
contemplando la idea y están en todo su
derecho de ser parte de la ausencia así
digamos lo consideran oportuno
antonio también le quiero preguntar si
con esta guerra también ha cambiado y ha
reforzado lo que es esta alianza militar
recordemos que en algún momento el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón dijo
que este organismo sufría de una muerte
cerebral que ha cambiado de entonces y
si está con esta confrontación esta
guerra nuclear ya le ha dado fuerza a
este organismo y la digamos importancia
también recordemos que fue criticada en
su momento y todavía por el que fuera
presidente de eeuu donald trump que si
nos da tiempo hablaremos de eso también
más adelante en esta conversación
sí correcto bueno recordemos que
paradójicamente donald trump es el
primer presidente en eeuu que entra en
conflicto como un aliado estratégico
como es de europa y sobre todo a nivel
de la otan por el tema de presupuesto
etcétera etcétera pero esta guerra en
ucrania definitivamente ha fortalecido a
una votante a través de los años ha
tenido algunas algunas debilidades
recordemos la guerra en la antigua
yugoslavia como la otan cya debilitó y
como la política exterior de los países
de la unión europea se había debilitado
fuertemente de cómo tratar el tema de la
guerra en la antigua yugoslavia pero la
guerra en ucrania por tratarse ya de una
potencia adversa a occidente en este
caso digamos rusia a pesar de que rusia
históricamente ya había sido invitada
siendo ya el sin presidente a ser parte
de lo que se conoce como la sucesión la
asociación por la paz que es considerada
como una antesala antes de entrar a la
otan pues evidentemente esta guerra en
ucrania este ha traído un
fortalecimiento de la organización a
pesar de que incluso francia también en
el pasado se había retirado de la otan
durante muchísimos años en la década de
los sesentas y francia ha sido una
nación este es un tema me parece
interesante de una vez decirlo francia
siempre he tratado de buscar cómo crear
un esquema ha sido muy crítico de la
otan históricamente y francia ha tratado
de buscar un esquema de defensa que sea
muy europeo no tanto de la mano de
washington que es la que lidera la otan
o la ha liderado históricamente desde
que se creó en 1949 sí entonces la
guerra en ucrania de alguna manera vino
de nuevo a cohesionar y la otan como tal
y eso obviamente sirve a los intereses
de washington en europa seguimos con
estos dos países ya para finalizar
antonio porque ya se nos acaba el tiempo
digamos esta conversación tan
interesante que hemos tenido nos queda
un minutito pero quisiera hablar
entonces de las amenazas internas que
enfrenta hoy esta alianza militar por
ejemplo en caso de ganar en francia la
candidata de extrema derecha marine
lepén la sacaría sacaría de su país del
comando integrado de esta organización
que nos ha descartado a poco como lo
como lo dije para para avanzar lo el
retorno a la casa blanca del presidente
del que fuera presidente de natra esto
en 2024 en las próximas presidenciales
si de hecho el extrema derecha que ha
crecido muy fuerte en europa a nivel de
partidos políticos a nivel de
movimientos en distintas instancias e
incluso hasta en el parlamento europeo
en las últimas elecciones al parlamento
europeo hace aproximadamente un poco más
de dos años en silla ya marine le pen
había comentado que quisiera llegar a
ganar la
presidencia de francia sacaría
eventualmente a francia sobre todo
también porque hay un pasado en donde ha
habido digamos rechazo hacia hacia la
otan y francia encabezado digamos un
poco esa dinámica de rechazo hacia la
otan entonces yo creo que fue marine
lepén sacaría eventualmente a francia y
vería que ver digamos qué impacto podría
tener un país tan fuerte como francia
dentro de europa una posible salida en
estos tiempos en donde hay una situación
de crisis hay una crisis sistémica que
la misma unión europea ha venido
enfrentando del punto de vista político
económico financiero y ahora digamos con
esta guerra en ucrania pues todo un
delay de multi hay de por medio todo un
dilema militar muy complicado